six français à connaître une carrière
internationale
alors si vous aimez les rayures la
provocation et l'art contemporain je
vous invite dans il ne faut jurer de
rien a adopté la buren attitude
ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
dans un instant vous allez pouvoir
suivre une partie de l'examen du projet
de loi de programmation militaire ce
texte a été adopté définitivement hier
par les sénateurs par fonds 86 voix
contre 145 après une vive polémique sur
la question du secret défense ce texte
prévoit en effet une extension du secret
défense à des lieux
la liste de ces lieux relevant du secret
défense sera désormais établi par un
arrêté du premier ministre
selon le sénateur socialiste robert
badinter il ya un immense danger à
désigner des lieux dans lesquels les
magistrats ne pourront plus se rendre
c'est un échec à l'état de droit at il
déclaré hier tout de suite donc
direction l'hémicycle pour revivre cette
polémique bonne après midi à tous sur
public sénat monsieur boulot.le 83,6
vous qu'il dépend des messieurs piras
pardon madame de messine après c'est le
président jean mimi chaque collègue cet
amendement tient à supprimer l'article 5
et permettez moi j'ai d'instants de
rappeler la définition d'une loi de
programmation militaire que je n'ai pas
inventé en surfant sur le site mrnf ans
voici ce que j'ai vu la loi de
programmation militaire couvrant une
durée égale à six années et l'acte
solennel par laquelle le parlement sur
proposition du gouvernement consacre
l'adhésion de la nation à la
constitution de l'instrument militaire
de la politique de la défense
la loi de programmation militaire est
ainsi au point de convergence de
plusieurs domaines politique militaire
mais également industriel économique et
financier elle est également un sujet
majeur d'intérêt pour un grand nombre
d'acteurs de ces sphères la
programmation pluriannuelle des crédits
permet à la défense de planifier
l'acquisition des équipements
nécessaires à l'accomplissement des
armées c'est ce que l'on voit sur le
site
après cette définition on devrait tous
interrogés sur l'opportunité de
l'article 5
cet article bouleverse l'organisation
des pouvoirs publics en matière de
défense et sécurité
il modifie le code de la défense suivant
les nouvelles orientations du livre
blanc sur la défense et la sécurité
nationale relative à l'organisation des
pouvoirs publics en matière de défense
et de sécurité nationale il organise
autour du président de la république une
concentration des pouvoirs il évite
impliquant l'extension du domaine
réservé les rôles du premier ministre et
de vous monsieur mise en défense se
trouve amoindrie à la faveur d'une
redistribution des responsabilités
inspiré du modèle américain de sécurité
nationale seul le ministre de
l'intérieur tire son épingle du jeu
il est à un glissement des pouvoirs vers
le ministre de l'intérieur qui trouve
grâce au concept flou de sécurité
nationale ses compétences
considérablement grossi en situation de
réponse aux crises majeures tout en
assurant la conduite opérationnelle des
crises d'ailleurs il faudrait qu'on
analyse de près cette notion de crise
majeure s'agit-il de la mise en cause
des intérêts de la nation de la sécurité
de la population d'une catastrophe
naturelle ou industrielle
est ce qu'il y aurait la tentation
d'employer différemment les forces
armées dans des situations de crise
intérieure et voulait rpr et vaughn
ministre je vous interpelle très
fortement et avec attention sur cette
notion
ce chapitre est en réalité en
programmation et pourrait mériter un
traitement haddock et un débat
particulier il modifie le contenu
l'ordonance 58,947 du 7 janvier 59
portant organisation générale de la
défense alors que cette ordonnance
intégré dans le code de la défense était
devenu au fil du temps l'un des
fondements du relatif consensus national
sur les questions de défense
en réalité cet article là pour faire
adopter sans véritable débat
les mesures préconisées par le livre
blanc du président nous pensons qu'une
autre démarche est possible le
gouvernement devrait soumettre à la
représentation parlementaire un projet
de loi sur la nouvelle organisation des
pouvoirs publics en matière de défense
la constitution n'est pas officiellement
et légalement modifié mais sa pratique
le sera d'ailleurs vous n'êtes pas sans
oublier monsieur le ministre que les
parlementaires socialistes membres de la
commission de rédaction du développement
avait démissionné pour protester contre
l'ingérence du président de la
république dans les travaux de la
commission et monsieur le ministre et
monsieur le président de la commission
contenu de vos origines
je vous mets en garde sur l'attention de
cette suppression
je sais que vous êtes soumis à un vote
conforme ce qui empêche tout débat
mais ce problème mérite sérieusement un
débat entre nous merci madame de messine
je rappelle que la défense d'un
amendement ces trois minutes madame de
messine interrompue avant mais je ne
laisserai pas passer une deuxième point
oui mais voilà merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
certes article 5 est un des articles
majeurs de cette loi on pourrait
pourtant s'étonner de le voir figurer
dans une loi de programmation militaire
car il traite d'une question
institutionnelle de fond qui est la
réorganisation des pouvoirs publics pour
les adapter à la nouvelle stratégie dite
de la sécurité nationale conscient que
votre projet de loi ne traiter ne
traitait pas que de programmation
militaire
vous avez d'ailleurs monsieur le
ministre rue d'ham en rajouter dans son
intitulé et diverses dispositions
concernant la défense
ceci vous permet donc par exemple de
modifier l'organisation des pouvoirs
publics de privatiser deux entreprises
ou bien encore de limiter le pouvoir
d'investigation des juges
cette nouvelle notion de sécurité
nationale est issu des réflexions menées
dans le cadre du livre blanc élaboré
l'an dernier et approuvé par le présent
la république
c'est une notion directement importée
des états unis et qui est à l'origine de
toutes leurs politiques publiques de
sécurité et de défense
elle inspire aussi la réflexion
actuellement en cours au sein de l'otan
pour renouveler ses concepts
stratégiques
bien que nous ne vient que nous vivions
dans un monde globalisé
je suis loin d'être persuadé qu'elles
correspondent à la vision que nous avons
en france des risques et des menaces
contre nos intérêts nationaux mais je
voudrais surtout avec cet amendement de
suppression marqué notre profonde
opposition aux modifications
institutionnelles
qu'implique cette notion ainsi que notre
refus de la concentration des pouvoirs
qu'elle entraîne à travers cet article
on assiste à une extension du champ de
la sécurité et du champ des compétences
du président de la république la défense
nationale devient alors un sous-ensemble
de la sécurité du pays qui englobe déjà
la sécurité intérieure
cet élargissement des notions implique
une concentration pyramidale des
pouvoirs du président de la république
ou sur les questions de sécurité
tout remonte à lui et tout procède de
lui
c'est ainsi que cet article 5 vise
notamment à remplacer l'actuel conseil
de défense et le conseil de sécurité
intérieure par un seul organisme qui
chapeautera l'ensemble le champ de
compétence de ce nouvel organisme sera
extrêmement étendu puisqu'il couvrira
toutes les questions et toutes les
politiques ayant trait à la défense et à
la sécurité nationale
quand on sait que ce nouveau conseil de
défense et de sécurité nationale
présidée par le chef de l'état se
déclinera en formation spécialisée
restreinte tout également présidé par
lui en particulier pour le renseignement
on mesure l'étendue du contrôle et des
pouvoirs présidentiels sur la sécurité
du pays
j'ajouterai enfin que nous débattons
aussi de la création d'un organisme qui
existe déjà depuis quelques mois puisque
le conseil national du renseignement
l'une des formations spécialisées du
conseil de défense et de sécurité
nationale est déjà en place avec son
coordonnateur nommé depuis quelques mois
c'est là encore un bel exemple de
fonctionnement d'organismes avant même
que la loi ne soit votée
ne voulant pas cautionner ce
déséquilibre institutionnel ni approuver
cette présidentialisation sans partage
et sans contrôle de la sécurité du pays
nous vous demandons d'adopter cet
amendement de suppression de l'article 5
nous allons demander l'avis de la du
rapporteur pour le 83e 125 coûtera
porter le reporter votre avis sur le
monsieur le président la commission ne
souhaite pas de modification texte de
l'article 5 telle qu'elle l'a approuvé
la vie et donc défavorable sur
l'ensemble des amendements qui ont été
discutées ou qui vont l'être
je voudrais revenir sur un certain
nombre d'arguments qui ont été avancées
à l'encontre de l'article 5 qui
actualise sans les bouleverser les
dispositions sur l'organisation des
pouvoirs publics en matière de défense
qui datait de l'ordonance de 1959
il ya d'abord le débat sur la notion de
défense et sécurité nationale qui a été
mise en exergue par le livre blanc et
dans lesquels certains voudraient voir
un changement fondamental de nos
conceptions politiques
je crois qu'il faut d'abord revenir aux
explications extrêmement précises qui
ont été donnés dans les travaux du livre
blanc la stratégie de sécurité nationale
prend en compte
je cite tous les phénomènes risques et
menaces susceptibles de porter atteinte
à la vie de la nation quelle que soit
leur nature militaire ou non militaire
quelle que soit leur origine intérieur
ou extérieur
il s'agit simplement de constater une
réalité savoir qu'il n'ya plus de césure
trancher entre la sécurité extérieure et
la sécurité intérieure et que les
vulnérabilités qui affecte notre
territoire nous d'autres populations ne
sont plus le fait de moyens militaires
classiques mais au contraire de mode
opératoire qui cherchent à contourner
nos moyens militaires ou notre puissance
technologique
il est donc nécessaire d'avoir une
vision plus globale de notre sécurité de
décloisonner les pouvoirs publics pour
accélérer les processus de décision de
réaction aux crises
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'attendent nos
concitoyens qui ne se soucie pas de
savoir si tel ou tel moyen relève plutôt
de la défense
ou de la sécurité je voudrais aussi dire
que la sécurité nationale ne se confond
pas avec la sécurité intérieure cela est
dit très clairement dans le livre blanc
la sécurité quotidienne et individuelle
des personnes et des biens
c'est à dire l'action courante des
forces de police et de gendarmerie ne
relève en rien la sécurité nationale il
peut pas y avoir de confusion sur ce
point al'inverse on voit bien que les
moyens importants que la programmation
consacre à la fonction connaissance et
anticipation participent à la sécurité
nationale au sens large et pas seulement
à la défense au sens strictement
militaire du mot c'est bien évidemment
le cas du renseignement et de ses moyens
humains et techniques
enfin on ne peut que s'étonner du
trouble que suscite l'association des
mots défense et sécurité
alors que depuis des années chacun parle
d'une politique européenne de sécurité
et de défense ça que ça provoque la move
le moindre état d'âme ou la moindre
discussion
nous souhaitons donc conserver cette
notion de défense et de sécurité alors
une autre objection émises à propos de
l'article 5 réside dans le fait qu'il
entraînerait une excessive concentration
des pouvoirs entre les mains du
président de la république la
constitution n'a pas changé sur ce point
elle donne au président de la république
des responsabilités éminentes
il est le garant de l'indépendance
nationale de l'intégrité du territoire
et du respect des traités
article 5 de la constitution ce qui le
place sur tout ce qui touche à la
défense et la sécurité nationale dans
une situation particulière très
différente de celle qui peut avoir sur
les autres domaines de l'action
gouvernementale
il est assis le chef des armées il
préside les conseils de défense article
15 l'élection suffrage direct puis le
quinquennat no fake renforcer la
responsabilité du chef de l'état en la
matière
par ailleurs le rôle du premier ministre
n'est pas modifiée il est même précisé
le premier ministre est étroitement
associée avec les ministres concernés
aux travaux placés sous l'autorité du
président je crois donc qu'il n'ya pas
lieu de voir dans l'adaptation du
dispositif
une quelconque dérive l'un des poids
l'importance ces récréations du conseil
national du renseignement qui remplace
effectivement une instance qui relevait
de matignon le comité interministériel
du renseignement et dont chacun
s'accorde à dire qu'elle ne parvenait
pas à jouer son rôle
la coordination du renseignement depuis
l'elysée avec la mission qui était
confié l'ambassadeur bajolet est de mon
point de vue une avancée très positive
l'inscription du conseil national du
renseignement dans la loi grâce à
l'article 5 me sont donc le
particulièrement utile j'ai déjà donné
l'avis défavorable sur l'ensemble des
amène alors je vais demander au
gouvernement de me donner son avis sur
le 80 325
à différentes reprises simplement pour
dire qu'il est quand même heureux que le
gouvernement soit cohérent avec le livre
blanc dans la loi de programmation
militaire c'est la moindre des choses
la deuxième chose c'est que j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion d'évoquer l'idée du conseil
national du renseignement répondants
monsieur chevènement hier sur la
nécessaire coordination et d'ailleurs et
sur le troisième point qu'on est un
conseil de défense comme nous en avons
aujourd'hui un conseil de défense et de
sécurité nationale ça ne change en rien
les responsabilités les attributions du
président de la république qui sous
toutes les majorités et ce toutes les et
c'est tout les septennats o'toole et
quinquennat une place éminente pour
définir les grandes orientations en
matière de défense et de sécurité pour
notre pays
il y a simplement dans cet article 5 les
conséquences du livre blanc d'une part
et d'autre part la redéfinition des
attributions de chaque ministre tout ça
me semble plutôt aller dans le bon sens
cinquante ans après l' ordonnance de
je vous remercie alors monsieur boulot
pour explication de vote
monsieur le président merci ça
simplement pour revenir un peu sur ces
cette concentration des pouvoirs à
l'elysée bon que personne ne veuille le
voir libre à eux
nous nous pensons au contraire
qu'effectivement il ya une concentration
dans tous les domaines j'ai même lu
aujourd'hui dans un hebdomadaire qui y
compris d'ailleurs la flotte des avions
qui étaient jusqu'à présent gérés par
matignon le sera directement par
l'elysée si c'est pas ça à la
concentration de tous les pouvoirs à
l'elysée la flotte des avions pour les
ministres un jeu précise en ce qui
concerne le conseil national du
renseignement j'aurais clé les choses
soient bien claires nous n'avons pas
contesté la mise en place d'un conseil
national du renseignement
et nous ne contestons pas le rôle du
coordonnateur du renseignement
ce que nous contestons c'est le
rattachement de ce conseil national du
renseignement auprès du président de la
république et pour être précis sous
l'autorité du secrétaire général de
l'elysée c'est ça qui est très
particulier c'est lui qui est chargé
coordonnées enfin de qui suit
hiérarchiquement au dessus du
coordonnateur du renseignement à dire
que lorsque vous nous expliquer que le
rôle du premier ministre reste éminent
chacun a pu s'apercevoir
qu'effectivement le rôle du secrétaire
général de l'elysée était devenu
imminent
d'ailleurs c'est monnaie courante de
dire qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement à
changer de rive et qu'il est concentré
aux 55 bis rue du faubourg saint-honoré
y compris d'ailleurs le ministère de la
défense alors jeu mais on voit la main
les deux amendements qui sont identiques
le 83 925 ceux qui sont favorables à
l'adoption veulent bien levé la main
quels sont ceux qui sont d'un avis
contraire
ils ne sont pas adoptées maintenant nous
avons 14 amendements qui font l'objet
d'une discussion commune
j'appelle le 84 c'est monsieur boulot
qui le défend non monsieur boutant avoue
premier monsieur monsieur mythe cet
article 5 nous proposons une nouvelle
rédaction et notamment celle ci le
gouvernement déposera à l'ouverture de
la prochaine session ordinaire 2009 2010
un projet de loi sur l'organisation des
pouvoirs publics en matière de défense
pourquoi parce qu'il s'agit de permettre
au gouvernement d'organiser un débat
parlementaire sur les changements
importants qu'il souhaite introduire
dans l'organisation des pouvoirs publics
en matière de défense un sujet dont on
revient abondamment de de parler je
voudrais simplement rappeler un certain
nombre de points
cet amendement propose au gouvernement
de soumettre à la représentation
nationale
un débat spécifique sur l'évolution de
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics en
matière de défense que le gouvernement
soit abordée il s'agit simplement d'une
question de cohérence
mes chers collègues les nombreuses
modifications continue à cet article
impose en effet un débat en profondeur
il modifie le code de la défense suivant
les nouvelles orientations du livre
blanc sur la défense et la sécurité
nationale relative à l'organisation des
pouvoirs publics en matière de défense
et de sécurité nationale
le contenu de l'ordonnancé auquel il a
été fait allusion numéro 59 147 du 7
janvier cinq ans
9 porte organisation générale de la
défense est modifié et très profondément
même et réorganiser donc au tour du
président de la république une
concentration de pouvoirs inédite jusque
dans un certain nombre de détails
convient de le rappeler notre collègue
didier boulaud les rôles du premier
ministre et du ministre de la défense se
trouve donc du coup atténuée à la faveur
d'une redistribution de responsabilité
le concept de sécurité nationale qui à
la fois par bien défini et imprécis
prend la place de la défense nationale
en revanche le ministre de l'intérieur
trouve son champ de compétences élargies
n'oublions pas qu'il hérite en outre
d'une force à statut militaire
enfin pour le moment la gendarmerie la
sécurité nationale résonne fortement
comme étant une nouvelle déclinaison de
la sécurité intérieure la mise en oeuvre
d'une politique qui mélange les notions
de sécurité de défense temps à créer une
zone commune sans frontières nettes ou
la politique de défense et la sécurité
intérieure apparaissent fusionner ça
mérite donc une nouvelle fois un débat
plus approfondi le transfèrement de la
gendarmerie au ministère de l'intérieur
et déjà une conséquence de cette
tendance imposée par l'exécutif
en l'état le gouvernement voudrait me
faire voter une loi de programmation
dans laquelle des modifications du code
de la défense
suivent les nouvelles orientations du
livre blanc sur la défense de la
sécurité nationale
aube socialiste pense que l'importance
des dispositions nouvelles impose donc
un débat devant la représentation
nationale
je vous remercie monsieur chevènement si
vous nous présenter le 5 rectifié plus
madame de bessines après
bien monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre il s'agit là encore au début du
premier alinéa du texte proposé de
distinguer la stratégie de défense est
celle de sécurité nationale je pense que
l'idée que la stratégie de sécurité
nationale englobe à la fois la défense
et la sécurité est tout à fait
contestable
d'autres l'ont dit avant moi c'est une
doctrine fort peu nationale c'est une
doctrine qui nous vient d'amérique et
qui est grosse de dérive par glissement
de la définition de l'ennemi vers sortes
d'ennemis intérieurs qui est peut-être
en contestataires mais il faut éviter de
criminaliser des attitudes qu'on peut
par ailleurs désapprouvé est critiqué
nous sommes en république
mais il me semble que il y à un danger
que vous ne semblez pas percevoir
je crois que cette idée de sécurité
nationale qui nous vient des états unis
nous amis à la remorque d'une certaine
manière de la politique de guerre contre
la terreur défini par monsieur mouche
mais on voit que la politique américaine
est sujette à des changements de cap
qu'il s'agisse de l'irak de l'iran de
l'afghanistan du pakistan
est-ce que nous sommes consultés quand
il y à des changements d'orientation
alors le conseil du renseignement
bien sûr mais je dirais les connexions
quand il y en a on peut les établir à
travers ce qui existe
je crois me souvenir que les conseils de
défense permettent aussi d'éviter milieu
intérieur
donc je vois pas de raison de changer ce
qui existe et qui fonctionne bien il
allait susciter des débats tout à fait
inutile avec eux
une conception de la sécurité nationale
qui se révélera en définitive très peu
opératoire est pleine de risques
je remercie madame de messine votre
moment s'il vous plaît qui est identique
cet article 5 qui vise à adapter
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics la
nouvelle stratégie sécurité nationale
définie par le livre blanc entretient
une confusion entre des notions et des
domaines différents
ça a été dit déjà plusieurs fois la
définition de la sécurité nationale qui
est donné dans cet article
par son caractère globalisant et peu
précis dit l'une totalement la notion de
défense nationale est en fait une
composante parmi d'autres de la sécurité
nationale dans cette conception de la
sécurité nationale les risques et les
nains et la nature des menaces ne sont
pas rares cheese et tout peut devenir
une menace la prolifération nucléaire
bien sûr les attentats terroristes
évidemment mais les attaques
informatiques
les tensions nées de l'accès aux
ressources naturelles les pandémies ou
bien encore les catastrophes naturelles
doivent-ils doivent-elles doivent-elles
être mises sur le même plan
quand tout devient menace les défenses
et les réponses adaptées sont beaucoup
plus difficile à concevoir
mais surtout si l'on partage cette
conception des choses les menaces contre
le pays et la population sont
multiformes est tellement diffuse
qu'elles peuvent provenir de partout de
l'extérieur mais aussi de l'intérieur
et pourquoi pas même de certaines
catégories de la population afin
d'éviter de tels risques de dérive
dangereuse pour notre état républicain
et démocratique
nous proposons par cet amendement de
bien distinguer la politique de la
défense nationale de celle de la
sécurité nationale je vous remercie pour
le groupe socialiste
monsieur vantomme la parole de 91
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre à mon tour moi aussi je vais
reprendre cette idée que il convient de
modifier le premier alinéa de ce texte
est de remplacer la stratégie de
sécurité nationale par les mots la
stratégie de défense
alors cet article apporte des
modifications majeures parce qu'il
organise autour du président de la
république une concentration de pouvoirs
inédite ça a déjà été dit les rôles du
premier ministre et du ministre de la
défense se trouve amoindrie à la faveur
d'une redistribution des responsabilités
qui sont inspirés du modèle américain
modèle américain de sécurité nationale
par ailleurs le concept de sécurité
nationale à la fois mal défini et
imprécis prend la place de lass équipe
de la défense nationale nous avions
critiqué ce concept de stratégie
sécurité drôle nationale lors de la
présentation du livre blanc il convient
de ne pas entretenir la confusion entre
sécurité des forces sécurité nationale
sécurité intérieure le livre blanc
devrait avoir été discutés et votés
parlement par le parlement pour avoir
une vision globale de la défense et de
la sécurité dans un cadre européen et en
conséquence définir la stratégie à
suivre et les moyens employés
la sécurité nationale semble n'être
qu'une nouvelle façon d'habiller la
sécurité intérieure or celle ci ne doit
pas être confondue avec la sécurité et
la défense
la mise en oeuvre d'une politique qui
mélange les notions sécurité défense
temps à créer une zone commune sans
frontières ou la politique de défense et
sécurité intérieure apparaissent
fusionner
l'article 15 de la constitution stipule
que le président de la république et le
chef des armées
il préside les conseils et les comités
supérieur de la défense nationale il
n'est pas question de sécurité nationale
mais de défense nationale il n'est pas
non plus question de conseil de défense
et sécurité nationale puisque le
gouvernement propose maintenant ces
changements faudra-t-il monsieur le
ministre
réformer
à nouveau la constitution je vous
remercie
maintenant monsieur chevènement vous
avez huit amendements qui se suivent
vous êtes le seul porte-parole de votre
groupe donc il faut que vous les
présenter tous les 8 de la façon qui
vous convient peut-être
globalement si ça vous convient
c'est une tâche difficile monsieur le
président que vous me confiez mêmes je
vous le dirai totalement impossible
parce que ces amendements n'ont pas le
même objet alors il faut quand même que
je rappelle que l'amendement 4 rectifié
qui a trait à l'article 5 vise à insérer
le mot et l'indépendance après
l'intégrité du territoire je crois il
s'agit de la politique de défense qui
doit assurer l'intégrité du territoire
et la protection des populations donc je
propose d'ajouter le mot et
l'indépendance la dépendance pour
impayés et l'acquisition ou la
préservation de son entière souveraineté
alors que l'intégrité territoriale
reposent simplement sur le droit d'un
état à préserver ses frontières s'était
pas même chose je pense que le rappel de
l'indépendance est particulièrement
opportun car il me semble que avec la
réintégration de l'organisation
militaire de l'otan avec des concepts
comme le concept de sécurité nationale
nous allons vers un monde qui sous
prétexte de multipolarité
d'interdépendance multiples sera un
monde où la france aura de la peine à
faire entendre sa voix et je suis de
ceux qui pensent que la france doit être
capable de faire entendre sa voix même
si elle est par certains à certains
moments isolé où paraît l'être
1 les événements viennent à son secours
il a vu par exemple en 2003 au moment de
l'invasion de l'irak
donc voilà je propose qu'il y ait quand
même un vote sur cet amendement
étant donné que je suis tout à fait
disposé à présenter une explication
d'ensemble pour tous les amendements
suivant qui se ressemblent relativement
puisque ils ont tous trait à la
confusion entre la défense et la
sécurité intérieure
donc voilà je propose quand même
monsieur le président que vous exerciez
autres bénévoles ans et que vous
souhaitiez au sénat un amendement dont
l'objet est quand même tout à fait
distinct de celui des autres oui c'est
seulement moi je veux tout bien
simplement pour la clarté du débat
jeunes comme ils font l'objet d'une
discussion commune
il m'est difficile de faire un vote
séparé maintenant sur celui là sauf s'il
y aura un vote séparé lorsque on aura
présenté l'ensemble des 14 amendements
maintenant si le rapportait le
gouvernement n'est d'accord avec le
sénat l'acceptent
moi je veux bien si ça simplifie si ça
arrange tout le monde
non c'est parce que monsieur chevènement
veut présenter les autres qui se
ressemblent beaucoup d'un d'un seul
ensemble donc on peut le faire si tout
le monde est niveau pas d'objection est
ce que vous êtes d'accord
dans ce cas là je vais demander à la
commission de donner la vie sur leucate
rectifié de monsieur chevénement
maintenant je ferai voter dessus avant
de faire voter les autres donné un avis
défavorable et vous monsieur nuit et
mois ci est alors je vais mettre aux
voix l'amendement numéro 4 rectifié de
monsieur chevènement quai pour qui n'est
pas favorable
il n'est pas adopté et maintenant vous
nous commenter les cet amendement qui
sont assez proches si j'en conviens j'ai
dérogé un petit peu aux habitudes mais
je vous remercie les uns et les autres
de votre compréhension
très bien je pense que c'était quand
même plus logique mais j'ai le président
mais peut-être que je n'entre pas dans
les arcanes du règlement ça m'étonnerait
quand même bon s'agissant des autres
amendements 3 rectifié de rectifier un
rectifié 6 rectifier cette rectifié 8
rectif
eh bien je crois et le neuf
ils ont tous pour objet de rétablir la
distinction entre la politique de
défense et la politique de sécurité
nationale
quelquefois ils se limitent à ajouter à
un ace après politique de défense et de
sécurité nationale pour montrer qu'il y
à bien deux politiques distincts pour le
reste il s'agit d'un amendement de
suppression ou d'amendements dont il
peut apparaître qu'ils sont de forme
ils sont deux formes sauf si on veut
bien considérer que c'est cette
confusion que nous critiquons qu' il n'y
a pas lieu de confondre le militaire et
le policier ce sont des métiers très
différents et je peux vous assuré par
expérience que le musée intérieur bien
entendu et vigilants sur la question du
terrorisme sur telle ou telle filière de
recrutement
enfin celle occupe très peu c'est le
cube très peu et vraiment c'est
regrettable d'en arriver à cette
confusion
donc voilà l'objet de ces amendements il
en étant cependant le 8 rectifié qui
précise que enfin qui vise à supprimer
un article
chaque ministre étant responsable de la
préparation et l'exécution des mesures
de défense qui incombe à son département
et il me paraît grave que cette
responsabilité soit étendue à la
politique de sécurité
parce qu'à seront là tous les ministres
vont se mêler au chi de sécurité vous
introduisez une confusion inimaginable
je vous remercie je vais demander
maintenant à madame voynet de me
présente de nous présenter les 43 44 le
veut bien
merci monsieur le président cet
amendement 43 a pour objet de compléter
l'article l 1142 6 du code de la défense
qui définit les responsabilités du
ministre des affaires étrangères
dans le domaine de la défense de la
sécurité nationale j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion au sud amendements présentés
précédemment d'expliquer combien les
fonctions de médiation et de prévention
des conflits revêtait un caractère
essentiel qu'elles pouvaient prendre
différents aspects appelé la mise en
place de moyens ainsi du ciel d'ampleur
capable de relayer l'action des ong dans
cet amendement
nous insistons tout particulièrement sur
le rôle du ministre des affaires
étrangères qui est le mieux à même
d'assurer une veille permettant
d'identifier les foyers de tensions
potentielles et de mobiliser les outils
de prévention des conflits dans un cadre
multilatéral
l'amendement numéro 44 complète les
responsabilités du ministre de la
justice dans le domaine de la lutte
contre la corruption et le blanchiment
d'argent sale
je lui ai rappelé ce matin ici même en
évoquant des études qui ont été
réalisées à ce sujet la corruption est
un frein au déploiement des petites
publique au développement à l'essor
démocratique et à la stabilité politique
nous ne sommes pas naïfs au point de
penser que cette plaine congrès drake
les pays d'afrique où les îles du
pacifique et que nous démocratie on
serait exemple nous savons que ces
mécanismes de corruption locale ou
nationale
on les implications internationales ne
serait ce que parce qu'aujourd'hui les
échanges économiques et les déplacements
se font à l'échelle mondiale et que la
déréglementation financière a offert
bien des facilités pour dissimuler les
méfaits des corrupteurs et des corrompus
l'impact sur la paix ne peut être
sous-estimée s'il ministre de la justice
concours effectivement à la coopération
judiciaire internationale
il me semble nécessaire monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre de mettre
l'accent sur l'action envers la
corruption et la délinquance financière
qui constituent des modes partiellement
grave d'atteinte aux intérêts
fondamentaux de notre pays c'est l'objet
cet amendement je vous remercie alors
maintenant je vais le sait
demandez l'avis du rapporteur sur les 13
amendements qui restent en discussion
commune
je considère que vous l'aviez déjà donné
fait donc un dell et le gouvernement
aussi long que avis défavorable sur
l'ensemble à la fois de la commission et
du gouvernement nous sommes bien
d'accord jeu mais on voit l'amendement
84 celui qui est de ceux qui sont
favorables l'adoption veulent bien levé
la main avis contraire il n'est pas
adoptée sur le 5 rectifié même vote sur
le 124 même vote sur le 91 même vote sur
le 3 rectifié même vote de rectifier
également à rectifier même vote sis
rectifié même 27 8 et 9 rectifié même
vote 43 et 44 même vote donc ces
différents amendements ne sont pas
adoptées et l'article 5
je le mets aux explications de vote mais
vous les explications de vote sur
l'article 5 que je me revois après ces
présidents simplement je voulais
rappeler que j'avais voté contre cet
article en commission il ya beaucoup de
très bonnes choses dans cette loi de
programmation militaire
mais cet article je ne le voterai pas la
confusion entre
la sécurité la défense ne me semble pas
approprié le texte sur la fusion de la
police et de la gendarmerie n'est même
pas encore votée du moins par le
parlement il a été voté par le sénat
mais pas encore par l'assemblée
nationale
quant à la confusion des genres des
genres elle a déjà fait ses preuves un
certain 16 juillet et je pense que ça
peut présenter un certain nombre de
dangers c'est pourquoi titre personnel
cet article je ne voterai pas bien alors
je mets ou voir l'article 5 ceux qui
sont pour l'adoption l'article au sein
club la main avis contraire il est
adopté
j'arbitre 3 rien de facile et à
l'article 6 je n'ai pas d'amendement je
le mets aux voix ceux qui sont absents
de l'option veulent bien levé la main
avis contraire il est adopté l'article 7
je suppose même vote ce qui les
supprimer mais je fais une confirmation
article 8
j'ai une demande de parole de monsieur
boutant vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président donc nous
sommes bien sûr l'article 8
n'est ce pas il s'agit d'un d'un
amendement visant à supprimer purement
et simplement cet article 8 pour quelles
raisons
cet article 8 du projet de loi en
apparence est d'une importance
secondaire par rapport au reste du
projet de loi dont notre assemblée
saisine loi des débats fondamentaux
relatifs à la définition de notre
doctrine de défense nationale de
sécurité intérieure etc ou financement
nos armées ou encore aux frontières du
secret défense
ne s'agit-il pas en effet de la simple
provocation d'un régime dérogatoire dont
bénéficient déjà et depuis le 1er
janvier 87
les immeubles appartenant au ministère
de la défense au moment de leur cession
par l'état
c'est effectivement le cas mais il me
semble que cette prolongation offre
justement l'opportunité idéale de
questionner la pertinence d'un
dispositif qui permet au ministère de la
défense de contourner un système qui
s'impose pourtant à l'ensemble des
autres administrations
le code général de la propriété des
personnes publiques prévoit en effet que
lorsqu'un ministère souhaite vendre un
immeuble dont il n'a plus besoin
il doit proposer aux autres services de
l'état le dit immeuble avant de pouvoir
procéder à la vente
ce n'est que lorsque l'immeuble est
reconnue inutile par tous les services
de l'état que le ministère peut le
remettre aux services chargés des
domaines afin qu'il procède à la vente
effective en 86 le législateur a jugé
cette procédure trop longue et estimé
que la spécificité des immeubles détenus
par le ministère de la défense devait
autoriser ces ministères à déroger à ces
règles et à pouvoir remettre les
immeubles concernés au service chargé
des domaines sans pour autant devoir
consulter au préalable les autres
services de l'état
cette dérogation était toutefois limitée
à une durée de 22 ans commençant le 1er
janvier 1987 vous l'aurez compris c'est
cette dérogation que l'article 8 vise à
prolonger car à compter du 1er janvier
2010 le ministère de la défense sera de
nouveau soumis au droit commun ou serait
de nouveau soumis au droit commun des
ventes d'immeubles par l'état au moment
même où la réorganisation du ministère
va le conduire à libérer de très
nombreuses emprise le gouvernement
estime que pour assurer au mieux la
reconversion des sites concernés
il est absolument indispensable de
prolonger le régime dérogatoire qui
permet au ministère de la défense
des cd des immeubles appartenant à
l'état sans se soucier des besoins des
autres administrations
il me semble pourtant qu'une bonne
gestion des biens publics imposent cette
concertation y compris s'il s'agit de
l'immeuble affecté à votre ministère
monsieur le ministre
au vu de certaines mésaventures
intervenus ces dernières années et je
pense par exemple au rachat par l'état
du bâtiment de l'imprimerie nationale
pour 376 millions d'euros après l'avoir
vendu 85 millions d'euros
quelques années auparavant
il me semble qu'en réalité chaque
cession d'un immeuble appartenant à
l'état devrait être mûrement réfléchi au
regard des besoins de l'ensemble des
administrations et services de l'état ou
de ses satellites
car s'il est une leçon à retenir de la
mésaventure de la vente de l'imprimé
nationale c'est bien que la vente
précipitée d'un immeuble ne rapporte
rien à ce dernier à savoir l'état et
risque même au contraire de lui coûter
très cher c'est la raison pour laquelle
groupe socialiste refuse la prolongation
du système dérogatoire dont bénéficie le
ministère de la défense et demande donc
tout simplement la suppression de cet
amendement de l'article ou des biens
alors qui défend nom du groupe
socialiste le thé monsieur 100 aux
discussions séparées le 87 qui le défend
je suis bhoutan
ce que dans cette maison nous avons déjà
eu beaucoup l'occasion de discuter de
questions de logement j'avais l'occasion
également d'échanger sur cette question
là au moment de la réunion delà de la
commission nous proposons que l'article
numéro 8 donc dans le cas où il ne
serait pas supprimé soit complétée par
le paragraphe suivant savoir lorsqu est
envisagé la cession d'immeubles affecté
au ministère de la défense y compris
dans un site ayant fait l'objet d'une
décision de restructuration prises par
le ministre de la défense
les organismes d'habitations à loyer
modéré mentionnée à l'article l 411 2 du
code de la construction et de
l'habitation doivent être préalablement
consultés par le service chargé des
domaines sur les projets de cessions
afin de leur permettre de soumettre une
proposition d'acquisition un décret
détermine les modalités de cette
consultation et les conditions d'examen
des propositions d'acquisition
auxquelles elles donnent lieu
je vous remercie
alors avis de la commission sur le 87
soit maintien de l'article 8 avis
défavorable sur le 86 sous ce président
le ministère de la défense a d'ores et
déjà pris des contacts pour transformer
certains sites qui souhaitent vendre en
logements sociaux notamment à paris il
existe beaucoup de sites libérés qu'ils
ne sont pas adaptés une reconversion en
logements la commission a considéré la
procédure de consultation systématique
n'était pas appropriée
par ailleurs on peut se demander comment
cet amendement pourrait s'articuler avec
des dispositions existantes du code des
domaines qui prévoit déjà une procédure
de publicité ainsi qu'avec des
dispositions spécifiques de cession à
l'euro symbolique aux collectivités
locales
dans le cas des restructurations avis
défavorable quel est l'avis du
gouvernement ce d'abord sur le 87 86 ans
est d'abord l'amendement de suppression
l'amendement de suppression bien entendu
nous nous souhaitons pouvoir céder
rapidement
et compte tenu de l'hétérogénéité notre
parc le l'idée de consulter l'ensemble
des services de l'état nous fédrun nous
ferait perdre un temps précieux
notamment pour la reconversion des sites
voilà pourquoi on veut la prolongation
quant à quant à l'autre amendement bien
entendu à chaque fois qu'une
collectivité souhaite faire du logement
social
nous sommes les premiers à accéder à sa
demande et d'ailleurs puis je vous
rappeler que chaque ville à la fois un
droit de priorité un droit de préemption
donc elle a tous les moyens pour si
l'état ne le souhaitait pas imposer du
logement social là où elle souhaite à
construire bien alors je mets au voile
amendement de 96 amendement de
suppression qui est pour et qui est
contre il n'est pas adopté et maintenant
l'amendement numéro 86 qui est pour
contre il n'est pas adopté et l'article
8 n'est pas modifiée jeu même vote je
suppose
il est donc adopté j'en arrive à
l'article 9
nous avons deux amendements mais qu'en
faire l'objet de discussions séparées
j'appelle tout d'abord le 45 de madame
voynet
et ensuite merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mesdames et
messieurs cet amendement est le suivant
ont fait l'objet de discussions
relativement longue en commission et je
veux dire je n'ai pas été convaincu par
les arguments que vous m'avez apporté
alors et il nous sommes que la rédaction
ambiguë de l'article 9 ans porte une
part de responsabilité
depuis 2007 le président de la
république et le gouvernement sont
lancés dans une campagne de
communication très efficace sur les
questions environnementales
affichant des ambitions louables le
grenelle de l'environnement n'est pas
encore votée que partout on érige déjà
en textes sacrés je ne ferai pas de
commentaire sur le plan de relance de
l'économie qui fait la part belle au
chant du passé notamment en matière de
transport routier pour m'en tenir au
secteur de la défense dont il faut
admettre qu'il présente aujourd'hui
nombreuses opportunités d'agir pour la
sauvegarde de l'environnement notamment
à l'occasion du
démembrements d'infrastructures devons
utiliser ou de la reconversion possible
de l'arsenal militaire
hélas il me semble qu'il n'en est rien
cet article 9 est l'antithèse même de ce
que prétend être une grenelle de
l'environnement puisque il subordonne la
cession d'un site à l'exécution par
l'acquéreur des travaux de dépollution
vous m'avez expliqué en commission
monsieur le ministre que pour vous la
phrase était clair subordonner la
cession d'un site à l'exécution ne
voulait pas dire que l'état fuyait ses
responsabilités en se dédouanant des
nuisances et des pollutions commises
du fait de ses activités pour moi les
choses ne sont pas aussi clairs en effet
rien ne dit que l'état devra déduire du
coup de cession du site le coût de la
remise en état de ce site qui excèdent
souvent sa valeur même on courait le
risque que les anciens sites militaires
il y en aura un certain nombre d'années
à venir
on les évalue à peu près à 83 qui seront
fermées au cours des prochaines années
demeurent des sites pollués et non
traités pourtant atteindre la santé
publique des riverains vous permettrez
et j'anticiperais sur l'amendement
suivant l'évoqué à un cas qui est un cas
tout à fait exemplaire puisqu'il montre
bien comment les couches de pollution
sont succédé au fil du temps je pense au
polygone d'expérimentation de
pontfaverger moronvilliers qui est un
équipement du commissariat l'italie et
admis qu rattaché à la direction des
applications militaires d'île de france
à côté de ce polygone on trouve
plusieurs centaines de tonnes d'obus la
première guerre mondiale qui sont
stockés sans protection sur un site
passoire plus tard ont été réalisés sur
le site
les premiers essais nucléaires en 1958
pour le programme de la bombe atomique
puis plus tard encore des expériences à
la fois de détonique mais aussi
d'observation de
d'expérience pour lesquels ont provoqué
des explosions chimique avec des
matériaux inertes dans tous les cas au
moment où on annonce la fermeture de ce
site
on se pose la question de savoir comment
va-t-on dresser le bilan de ce qui s'y
trouve et comment va-t-on le dépolluer
le maire de la commune s'inquiète
fortement vous avez monsieur le ministre
adressée en décembre 2007
le plan d'action environnement du miss à
la défense au directeur de votre
administration centrale du ministère
ce plan prévoit que chaque année à
partir de 2008
le mini ça préparera un bilan
environnemental des activités portant
notamment sur ses rejets gazeux et
liquides c'est production de déchets ses
consommations d'énergie et d'eau ainsi
qu'à bilan carbone à ma connaissance yen
n'a été fait monsieur le ministre et
rien n'a été publié mais surtout ce
document est très peu bavard pour ce qui
concerne l'europe de la remise en état
des sites militaires
le premier amendement vise à revenir
dans le régime commun
le second amendement que je vous propose
visa ce qu'une échéance soit fixée pour
la remise en état de ces sites
merci je vais consulter le rapporteur
sur un 45 de bord lors de l'examen du
texte en commission le ministre nous a
donné des exemples très concrets de
blocage que l'article ne permettra de
lever sans remettre en cause le biais
senégal de dépollution sur le 40 si cet
amendement est contraire à l'objet même
de l'article 9 puisqu'il temps imposé à
l'état
la dépollution préalable avant cession
alors qu'il s'agit de permettre à
l'acquéreur d'exécuter les travaux de
dépollution donc avis défavorable quel
est l'avis du gouvernement sur les 45 et
46 risque de me répéter une nouvelle
fois jésus nous sommes encore
aujourd'hui propriétaires de terrains
qui date peut-être des des plans de
restructuration joxe ou où j'ai pas où
les retards de 92 94 parce que l'état
n'a pas de quoi financer ces travaux de
dépollution et nous trouvons me
semble-t-il un dispositif qui est qui
devrait confond qui devrait au contraire
obtenir la lune et l'unanimité dans la
mesure où sous le contrôle de l'état
nous permettons à l'acquéreur de pouvoir
faire la dépollution pour permettre la
reconversion du site le plus rapidement
possible si bien entendu le site
si la dépollution coûtent plus cher que
le site l'état prendra à sa charge le
différentiel est donc ça va permettre à
des collectivités moi j'en connais je
rencontre régulièrement des
parlementaires députés sénateurs maires
me disant mais ce qu'un jour vous allez
me permettre de pouvoir faire quelque
chose avec ce site on va enfin pouvoir
permettre à des collectivités de prévoir
des reconversions de sites en faisant en
sorte que on leur donne les moyens de
réaliser par eux mêmes la dépollution je
prends un exemple simple vous avez à la
londe dans le var un site de 13 ou 14
hectares en place centre-ville je crois
que je vous ai déjà donné cet exemple
aux commissions où le maire de la londe
bien voir en disant mais est-ce qu'un
jour vous allez me me dégager de cette
verrue en plein centre-ville de est au
bord du littoral de ma commune et bien
désormais on aura là les moyens de
permettre aux collectivités de pouvoir
se lancer dans des travaux de
dépollution ou un promoteur privé tout
ça sera fait sous le contrôle de l'état
et je crois que très sincèrement il
s'agit d'un dispositif qui garantit
qu'ils donnent les contrôles nécessaires
et les assurances nécessaires et qui en
même temps permettra d'activer la
reconversion si nombreux sites qui
traînent souvent depuis 10 ans ou 20 ans
comme propriété de l'état parce que nous
n'avons pas les moyens de dépolluer bien
madame gonnehem fort explications de
vote oui merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre nous avons
effectivement eu cette discussion en
commission mais je continue une passe
est convaincu pourquoi parce que je vous
ai proposé en commission de bien
préciser par l'ajout d'un alinéa que le
prix de vente serait amputé du coût de
la remise en état du site en incluant
notamment les réparations
environnementale m'avait expliqué
victime ans qui avait pas de problème
que je devais me contenter de votre
parole sauf que dans les textes rien ne
prévoit que lorsque effectivement le
site et cc est cédé à l'euro symbolique
l'état met au pot pour financer la
dépollution
dès lors qu'ils seraient cédés à une
commune où conservatoire du littoral qui
serait totalement incapable de financer
cette dépollution et vous reconnaissez
que l'état n'a pas de quoi financer des
pollutions
c'est donc bien qu'il y aura une sorte
de pression qui sera exercée sur les
communes pour qu'elles se lancer pour
qu'elle fasse à la place de l'état
ce que celui ci n'a pas su faire je
croyais bien volontiers que tous les
gouvernements qui se sont succédés se
sont heurtés à la même difficulté mais
là je constate qu'une commune
d'effectivement confronté à une verrue
au plein coeur de son territoire
nos gras guère le choix elle devra
hérité du site pollué est débrouillé je
comprends que ça vous fasse plaisir
je pense que c'est un cadeau empoisonné
que vous faites a beaucoup de ces
communes beaucoup des sites du
conservatoire du littoral ont été
confiés en gestion par l'armée sans
diagnostic préalable
certains d'entre eux ont servi terrain
d'entraînement ont servi de terrain de
manoeuvre je suis à peu près certaine qu
aucun bilan sérieux leur état réel au
titre de l'environnement et d'un
éventuel impact sanitaire de la
pollution n'a été réellement fait bien
alors je mets aux voileux 45 et pour
avis contraire
il n'est pas adopté et je pense 46 même
vote pas d'objection il n'est pas adopté
et l'article 9 que le met aux voix même
vote
il est adopté ensuite nous arrivons à
l'article 10 où j'ai une demande de
parole de monsieur jean pierre godefroy
et de la parole oui monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
depuis quelques années le ministère de
la défense est en paix d'évolution mais
l'année 2009 restera sûrement marquer
d'une pierre noire
en témoigne cette loi de programmation
militaire qui entérine à la fois les
conclusions du livre blanc de la défense
et les conséquences de la rgpp
cela était déjà dit plus tôt dans le
débat par mes collègues du groupe
socialiste si nous comprenons la
nécessité de certaines évolutions nous
ne partageons pas le sens de celles que
vous mettez en place qui consiste
principalement à externaliser les
activités industrielles et de soutien
avec 54 mille suppressions d'emplois
civils et militaires à la clé
c'est en fait monsieur le ministre un
véritable démantèlement de notre outil
de défense que vous avez engagé
dcns n'échappe pas n'échappe à cette
funeste règles comme le prouvent
l'article 10 de ce projet de loi qui
fait rentrer l'entreprise dans le droit
commun des privatisations
en 2001 j'avais voté contre le
changement de statut et en 2004 au nom
du groupe socialiste
j'avais déjà exprimé mes craintes quant
au risque d'éclatement de des scènes et
sa filialisation tout azimut
monsieur le ministre on m'avait répondu
en substance en 2004 aucun risque
le législateur a prévu des garde-fous et
bien aujourd'hui ce sont justement ces
garde-fous qui sont remis en cause
puisque comme le dit explicitement
l'exposé des motifs du projet de loi
ils constituent des obstacles mes chers
collègues de la majorité
je me souviens des propos rassurants que
tenait à l'époque le rapporteur du texte
le transfert collègue yves fréville il
se plaisait à souligner la protection
garantie par le recours aux législateurs
au delà de certains seuils ou effectif
aujourd'hui en bonne logique libérale
c'est justement le recours aux
législateurs qui est un obstacle et il
faut donc commettre tout signe
d'appartenance de dcn au secteur public
j'avoue mes chers collègues ne pas
comprendre pourquoi la majorité
nombre d'entre vous étaient déjà là qui
en 2004 avait sciemment jugé nécessaire
de prévoir des dispositions dérogatoires
au droit commun des privatisations
lorsque les opérations filialisation
était assorti d'un transfert d'actifs de
dcn choisi aujourd'hui de se déjuger
que sont devenus les risques de dérives
dont vous parliez en 2004 ont ils
subitement disparu en 2009
pour ma part ma position sur le sujet
reste inchangé je reste persuadé que la
question de possibles coopérations
industrielles ponctuelle avec d'autres
industriels ne peut être que se
concevoir que dans un schéma de
conservation des patrimoines et des
missions de chacun ou de cela le
processus de filialisation privatisation
ouvert en 2004 a ouvert la boîte de
pandore aujourd'hui c'est l'unicité de
dcns qui est remise en cause de même que
son avenir comme industrie de défense
depuis plusieurs années et notamment
depuis l'entrée de thales dans les
capitales des scènes la stratégie du
groupe est très clair il s'agit de
recentrer ses activités vers
l'ingénierie et le commerce est
d'externaliser de plus en plus les
moyens de production sans même parler de
l'avenir des sites français
il me semble que ce recentrage ne
correspond pas à l'urgence d'une
véritable politique industrielle dont
notre pays a besoin et conduirait aux
mêmes déboires que ce qu'ont connu il ya
quelques années les chantiers civils qui
sont allés trop loin dans
l'externalisation de certaines
compétences voire dans certains domaines
comme l'électronique
le concept absurde d'entreprises sans
salarié dans le cas présent avec des
salariés de production a minima c'est ce
que vous proposez pour l'instant l'année
dernière à l'occasion de l'examen du
budget 2009
je vous interrogeait pour connaître
votre stratégie votre projet industriel
monsieur le ministre
concernant dcns alors même qu'à cette
époque le président de la république
parlait de rapprocher les constructions
navales civiles et militaires
c'est à dire il l'avait dit
explicitement des scènes et les
chantiers de l'atlantique
vous aviez été dans l'embarras pour me
répondre et aujourd'hui encore j'ai le
sentiment que vous aurez beaucoup de mal
à répondre à cette question
la preuve en est s'il le faut que le
contrôle d'entreprises pures année
pluriannuel conclu conclut pardon entre
l'état et la société est arrivé à
échéance en 2008
et aucun nouveau contrat n'a depuis été
élaboré ce contrat là d'ailleurs pas été
respectées de même que n'a pas été
respecté l'engagement du gouvernement de
transmettre aux commissions des finances
et de la défense du parlement
chaque année jusqu'au terme de la
période d'exécution du contrat un
rapport sur les perspectives d'activité
et les fonds propres de la société
cela aurait pourtant dû être obligatoire
aux termes de l'article 78 de la loi de
finances rectificative pour 2011 vous
comprendrez donc notre inquiétude à
l'égard de cet article 10 qui supprime
la des derniers moyens de contrôle du
parlement sur la stratégie de dcns
ce qui m'inquiète également dans cet
article 10 c'est le sort fait aux
personnels de tous statuts
là encore l'exposé des motifs du projet
de loi est très claire il s'agit de
faire sauter des obstacles
administratifs qui empêche la mise à
disposition des personnels de dcns dans
les sociétés où elle est minoritaire
vous tenté de rassurer les personnels en
affirmant qu'il n'est pas question de
remettre en cause leur statut et en les
assurant qu'il peut revenir au sein de
dcns il ya peu se libère si un peu se
libère c'est pour le moins insuffisant
alors même que la mobilité accrue et
sans limites des personnels dans le
groupe aura pour conséquence de rompre
les liens géographiques entre les
individus et leur lieu de travail et
sans doute de modifier les contrats de
travail les accords collectifs
en fait il n'y aura pas monsieur milices
de retour possible
c'est le but poursuivi pour accélérer
l'extinction du statut d'ouvrier d'état
qui est votre véritable objectif
il ne faut d'ailleurs pas oublié de
mettre ses dispositions en relation avec
celle de l'article 29 du projet de loi
sur la mobilité et les parcours
professionnels dans la fonction publique
que vous avez fait voter en catimini
l'assemblée nationale le 3 juillet
dernier il permet à votre ministère
d'externaliser certaines de ses missions
est de mettre les personnels du
ministère à disposition des opérateurs
privés
quelle que soit leur catégorie
fonctionnaires militaires et ouvriers
d'état cela revient à organiser le
démantèlement du ministère de la défense
et à remettre en cause le statut des
différentes catégories de personnels une
fois mis à la disposition des
entreprises privées ou leurs filiales
les personnels civils et militaires du
ministère de la défense se retrouveront
soumis aux dispositions du code du
travail
avec des garanties bien moins
importantes que celles prévues par leur
statut
vous affirmez monsieur le ministre que
le dispositif reposera sur le
volontariat le volontariat on en parlait
la semaine prochaine sur le travail
dominical
mais c'est toujours la même chose de
rien ça marche que dans un sens et sur
la possibilité du retour au ministère
c'est une illusion monsieur le ministre
puisque conclure s'il vous plaît oui je
conclu monsieur le président c'est une
illusion je répète monsieur le ministre
puisque une fois la mission externaliser
le ministère de rappeler l'utilité des
compétences de ses personnels en cas de
difficultés dans la société choisie pour
l'externalisation d'actualisation le
chômage sur la seule solution pour ces
personnels c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous demandons la suppression de cet
article vous me permettrez un monsieur
le président je vais pour très peu de
temps dans votre propos liminaire en
début de texte
vous êtes réjouit d'avoir redonné vie à
l'école des mousses sont créés l'an je
crois 150 postes
j'aurais aimé que vous rige réjouissiez
d'avoir redonné vie aux écoles des
apprentis de la marine ces écoles qui
étaient des modèles de promotion sociale
école de rugby républicaine s'il en est
école du mérite ça n'aurait pas laissé
insensible le président de la république
qui en parle beaucoup mais qui avait
comme défaut est grave défaut c'était de
former les ouvriers déterrait statuts et
des ingénieurs des construction navale
militaire jeu en porter le solent barter
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues je vais
répondre à monsieur deux fois ce qui
permettra d'expliquer les raisons pour
lesquelles je suis les favorable à tous
les amendements qui seront présentés sur
cet article 10 ce godefroy j'ai comme
vous l'avantagent d'avoir dans mon
département un établissement de la dcn
donc je crois que je connais un peu le
problème est ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que en 2001 quand vous vous êtes
opposé vous monsieur votre froid au
changement de statut proposé par le
ministre de la défense de l'époque
monsieur richard la situation de laisser
n était véritablement catastrophique
c'était un service de l'état qui
fonctionnait très mal les dcn avait un
un plan de charge
si peu fournie que il a fallu avoir
recours aux collectivités locales et
notamment à la région de bretagne pour
donner du travail à dcn
nous avons été contraints de financer
des plateformes pétrolières comme si
c'était la vocation de la dcn ceci a
amené cette situation désastreuse
les ministres sauter et richard a
envisagé l'étape de changer le statut de
la dcn et de le changer en société
anonyme contrôlée par l'état bien
entendu puisque c'est à 100% du capital
d'état et moi je crois aux histoires qui
réussissent or c'est ce changement de
statut qui a permis à la dcn de se
lancer sur un marché où il ya une
concurrence qui est extrêmement forte de
montrer la qualité et l'excellence de
ses ingénieurs comme de ses ouvriers
mais de pouvoir justement se présenter
dans les meilleures conditions
sortir des produits qui était demandé et
aujourd'hui le plan de charge de la dcn
et non seulement assuré mais ce que la
lycéenne ne pouvait pas faire
convenablement elle le fait aujourd'hui
fort bien grâce à son statut
c'est de devenir un exportateur est un
exportateur et dont les produits se
vendent très bien puisque nous avons
vendu des sous-marins récemment au
brésil
voilà déjà un des avantages du
changement de statut beaucoup plus de
souplesse et aussi eu beaucoup plus de
recettes ce qui est une somme importante
deuxième étape extrêmement importante la
possibilité de procéder à des
regroupements il ya des synergies et la
dcns à cause d'ailleurs de sa bonne
situation
un pu acheter thales navale fait qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui vraiment elle
devient extrêmement compétitive dans le
domaine maritime est là les gammes de
produits diversifiés alors évidemment on
a pris des précautions en effet pour
s'assurer que même si d'ailleurs thales
est entré au capital de dcns est une
activité où l'état est parfaitement
dominant tout est contrôlé et tout le
reste
il se trouve que quand de la dcn doit
aujourd'hui fondé des filiales communes
avec d'autres entreprises ce qui est
indispensable elle ne peut pas le faire
dans les conditions qui sont celles des
entreprises publiques et il faut lui
donner beaucoup plus de souplesse
parce que si nous voulons demain avoir
une europe de la défense dont vous nous
dites suffisamment qu'elle n'existe pas
il va falloir que nous sachions créé des
partenariats industriels avec d'autres
pays et dcn et justement une entreprise
qui permettra d'y arriver parce que ceux
des scènes est une excellente entreprise
et ses filiales
aujourd'hui il est à partir du moment où
l'état d'ailleurs conserve une golden
share ou une action spécifique qui
contrôlent à peu près l'exercice dans
toutes les filiales dans lesquels elle
va même minoritaire je vois pas où est
le danger je vois pas où est le
démantèlement genevois au contraire que
des avantages aux formules qui nous sont
présentés parce que ça permettra
justement à dcn d'étendre sa gamme et de
pouvoir réaliser un certain nombre
d'opérations qui lui était jusque là
interdite
donc il s'agit d'un progrès et à mon
avis de l'achèvement d'un processus qui
est né en 2001 c'est le mérite de
monsieur richard de l'avoir ouvert nous
en tirons les conséquences et c'est
pourquoi comme il s'agit d'une bonne
opération
je donnerai un avis défavorable à tous
les amendements qui contredisent cette
opération nous avons une suppression bon
je vais donc appelé le 10 rectifié de
monsieur chevènement tout d'abord suite
monsieur godefroy je considère défendu
s'il est d'accord
oui sans sa parole aurait pu interpréter
vient cet amendement rejoins tout à fait
celui de monsieur godefroy
je n'ai pas davantage de voir un
établissement de la dcns dans ma
circonscription
1 par conséquent je posais des questions
simples de quoi s'agit-il vraiment
s'agit de créer des filiales minoritaire
fait lille vient minoritaire alors
qu'aujourd'hui ne sont autorisés que des
filiales majoritaires par définition
quand on est minoritaire
on n'est plus le patron j'entends
monsieur le président de la commission
des restes rangèrent et de la défense de
dire qu'il y aura une golden share je ne
les vues nulle part et je ne sais même
pas de quelle filiale minoritaire nous
parlons s'agit-il de se défaire de notre
capacité à produire des sous marins à
propulsion classique
s'agit-il de rentrer dans un consortium
à dominante anglo saxon ou allemandes
enfin nous nous posons la question de
savoir ce qu'est la politique
industrielle que vous voudriez faire à
partir du moment où l'autorisation vous
serez par le parlement de créer des
filiales minoritaires monsieur truc qui
parlait justement d'entreprise sans
usine ait quitté le grand spécialiste de
l'externalisation puisqu'il a réussi à
faire de ce magnifique fleuron de notre
industrie qui était alcatel alsthom
entreprise où lui-même d'ailleurs plus
salariés parce que voilà considérer que
ça suffisait comme ça et bien
très franchement ça nous incite à
regarder avec une certaine réticence
cette possibilité de faire on ne sait
pas où ni pourquoi faire des filiales
mais nord-eclair donc voilà l'objet de
cet amendement de suppression si un jour
c'était nécessaire au nom d'alliance
européenne ferait revenir devant le
parlement nous présenter le dossier et
je suis persuadé que l'effet parlerait
de même nous pourrions être convaincu
monsieur le rapporteur est ce qu'on peut
pas représenter les trois amendements
banque vous préfet demande à répondre à
monsieur a répondu qu'il pose une
question précise je lui apporter une
réponse précise
je ne crois pas qu'il s'agit du
démantèlement de la dcn quand il s'agit
de fonder une filiale ou la dcn sera
minoritaire avec véolia pour enlever les
ordures ménagères des bases françaises
1 franchement ça permet de faire ce
genre de choses
alors je ne vois pas vraiment où est le
problème
bien monsieur vote soit vous nous
présenter votre amendement oui monsieur
le président je défendrai mon amendement
en répondant par là même monsieur le
rapporteur pour lui dire qu'en 2001 le
gouvernement de gauche et donc le
ministre monsieur richard avait pris la
précaution même si à titre personnel je
n'étais pas d'accord pour des raisons
que chacun connaît a et pris la
précaution très judicieuse essentiel
c'est être changer le statut mais de
maintenir l'état à 100% du capital et
donc la logique qui prévalait à l'époque
il y aurait pu continuer à prévaloir
6ème au changement de majorité
c'était que des scènes restent bien une
entreprise d'état contrôler complètement
par l'état et celle changement de statut
comme vous l'avez dit pouvait peut-être
permettre peut-être permettre d'avoir
des entrées sur certains marchés ceci
étant moi je vais vous dire monsieur le
rapporteur
je ne suis pas persuadé que ce soit le
changement de statut de dcns qui est
permis de
gagner des marchés c'est la compétence
c'est la compétence de ces deux des
employés c'est la compétence des
ingénieurs
c'est la qualité du travail fourni qui
gagne les marchés beaucoup plus que le
statut est d'ailleurs les contrats qui
ont été passés entre 2001 2004 qui sont
venus ensuite n'avait pas besoin de ses
filiales minoritaires pour être passé on
n'a pas vendu des sous-marins au
pakistan et au alingue les les agosta
les scorpène en dix ans rassurez vous on
va avoir des filiales minoritaires ils
se sont foutus complètement il passé des
contrats parce que nous avions des
bâtiments qui était très bien fait qui
était compétitif sur le plan
international quant aux eaux plates
formes vous savez ça s'éteint à l'heure
moi j'ai jamais vu des scènes fabriquer
des plateformes pétrolières
je n'ai pas vu fabrique et on l'a
c'était à l'heure pendant quelques temps
il ya eu 1 à brest une tentative qui
était à l'heure à l'époque moi je ne
pensais pas que ce soit une vraie une
solution je ne pensais pas été une
solution
et d'ailleurs on sait très bien ce sera
un autre débat qui avait une entreprise
qui fabriquait des plates formes
pétrolières s est situé en normandie pas
loin de chez moi ça s'appelait lieu à
l'époque et qu'il n'a pas pu continuer à
faire cette ses fabrications parce que
nous n'étions pas à cette époque
compétitif donc c'est un autre débat
mais pour revenir à dcns donc pour
défaire topo pour pour revenir à dcns je
ne suis pas je ne suis pas persuadé du
tout que ce soit ce que vous voulez
faire aujourd'hui qui changera sa
capacité à convaincre sur des marchés
par contre par compte
je le crois ce qui est dangereux ce qui
est dangereux c'est que progressivement
la capacité industrielle qui fait
justement la renommée de dcn risque de
disparaître
c'est le coeur de métier on parle de
coeur de métier au sénat on parle de
coeur de métier quand on parle des
hôpitaux barça c'est le coeur de métier
est le coeur de métier ce sont ceux qui
fabriquent ce ne sont pas uniquement
ceux qui vendent ce sont ceux qui
fabriquent et moi je peux vous dire
monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre c'est qu'on peut
prendre aussi des risques quand nous
n'aurons plus les capacités de fabriquer
nous mêmes
cette autosuffisance à fabriquer que
nous serons dépendre d'autres pour
fabriquer externalisés ailleurs on peut
avoir un jour aussi des problèmes de
construction et vous savez très bien
monsieur le rapporteur que l'idée germe
dans l'esprit de certains
si je vous dérange jeu
terme et je pense que oui oui une cinq
secondes terminé ses voix voilà et donc
j'ai terminé on sait très bien l'idée de
vouloir fabriquer des des sous-marins
qu'on ferait qu a semblé par tronçon qui
viendraient d'ici ou de là on le
reconnaît cette cette volonté c'est la
volonté effectivement de faire en sorte
que dcn ne soit plus lente reprise
industrielle de fabrication qui nous est
indispensable
merci de m'avoir accordé 15 secondes de
plus pour le dire chers collègues je ne
pense pas abuser dans cet hémicycle du
temps je trouve que c'est quand même un
petit peu mais ce cadre voulant me
reprendre pour cinq secondes à moi
qu'est-ce que je dise vous dérange
beaucoup
madame de messine voulez monsieur view
vous présenté l'amendement 123,6
monsieur le président je crois qu'il ya
effectivement des débats qui mérite que
l'on prenne le temps il y à des chats
qu'il faut appeler des chats parce que
cet article 10 ans prétendant donner à
notre société nationale de construction
navale dcns la possibilité de mieux se
développer à l'international et dans de
nouveaux secteurs d'activité propose
tout à fait autre chose car pour cela
vous voulez faire entrer dcns dans le
droit commun des privatisations en
assouplissant les conditions de création
de filiales et de prise de participation
dans lesquels la société ne détiendrait
plus qu'une part minoritaire et
parallèlement vous modifier les règles
de mise à disposition des ouvriers de
l'état et de détachement des
fonctionnaires avec ces nouvelles
dispositions qui vont encore plus loin
que ce qu'autorise la loi de décembre
nous entrons oui effectivement dans un
processus rampant de changement de
statut de cette société d'un intérêt
stratégique est essentielle à notre
défense nationale
je crains qu en l'autorisant avec
beaucoup plus de souplesse à céder des
branches de son activité à des
entreprises extérieures au groupe ce ne
soit cette fois ci
l'ultime étape du démantèlement de cette
entreprise intégrée cela s'accompagnant
de l'organisation d'une mobilité accrue
de ses personnels de tout statut les
personnels toutes catégories confondues
et leurs organisations syndicales sont
assis
légitimement inquiets pour leur avenir
et celui de leurs entreprises qui
privilégient de plus en plus la
rentabilité au détriment des objectifs
de production industrielle l'état actuel
de la législation permet pourtant déjà à
dcns de créer des filiales où elle est
minoritaire quand il s'avère nécessaire
de rassurer des partenaires étrangers
réticent à une trop grande place de
capitaux publics français par exemple
ainsi l'entreprise est déjà minoritaires
dans des filiales qu'elle a créée en
asie du sud-est ou en italie je me méfie
d'autant plus de ces nouvelles
dispositions que la loi de 2001
prévoyait que le parlement puisse être
régulièrement informé de la situation
des cns or ces rapports réguliers n'ont
jamais vu le jour comme cela a déjà été
souligné
je pense donc que ces nouvelles
dispositions soi-disant nécessaire à de
nouvelles alliances industrielles qui ne
sont pas clairement énoncés sont en fait
révélatrice d'une politique industrielle
de défense menée au coup par coup par au
niveau européen
monsieur le ministre je ne vois pas avec
ses possibilités de céder des branches
d'activité des sites extérieurs au
groupe dcns
où est la préservation et le
développement de nos base industrielle
et technologique de défense dont vous
aimez tant vous réclamez j'y vois même
un danger certain de perdre de notre
maîtrise nationale sur le secteur
stratégique de la construction navale
militaire pour cet ensemble de raisons
je vous invite comme mes collègues à
voter cet amendement de suppression de
l'article 10 je vous remercie alors
monsieur le rapporteur je pense que vous
êtes déjà exprimé en défavorable sur le
ministre simplement quelques mots je
dire si monsieur richard quand il a été
mise la défense a massacré les les
crédits d'équipement du ministère de la
défense et des armées
il aura à son actif une des très belles
réformes qu'il a eu le courage de
monnaies qui a été de transformer dcns
en société anonyme
ceux qui étaient dans l'hémicycle en
2001 ont dû d'ailleurs voter cette
réforme à l'exception
de monsieur godefroy et je suis très
heureux de porter aujourd'hui la
continuité d'une réforme qui a été
engagé par le gouvernement de lionel
jospin
à l'époque il s'agissait d'une réforme
qui nous a permis de faire en sorte que
dcns soit aujourd'hui une entreprise
autour de laquelle nous pourrons mener
les grandes restructurations
industrielles européennes dont nous
avons tellement besoin dans le secteur
de l'industrie navale et de la
construction navale
nous sommes dans cette situation
absolument extraordinaire c'est que les
européens surtout les marchés se font
concurrence en permanence alors que vous
savez quel est le niveau des crédits
budgétaires en matière de défense en
europe par rapport à d'autres
concurrents et donc nous avons grâce à
grâce à cette évolution statutaire et
grâce à cette proposition que nous
faisons qui est ce qui est très simple
c'est qu'on va permettre à dcns de
pouvoir passer des accords avec un
certain nombre d'entreprises européennes
ou des sénès ne sera pas majoritaires
mais où elle sera en mesure de pouvoir
contrôler une partie d'entre eux prix je
prends un exemple nous voulons nous
voulons construire un mba de la torpille
avec une fée finmeccanica et bien nous
aurons là l'occasion de pouvoir
transférer une partie des actifs de dcns
est de construire un inducteur un acteur
industriel majeur sur le sujet sur ce
sujet majeur qui représente les
torpillages prend un deuxième exemple
nous avons décidé de mettre 100 millions
d'euros pour la déconstruction du
matériel d'armement et notamment du
marié matériel naval
je ne sais pas ce que fera des crs en la
matière mais qui vous dit dcns ne
pourrait pas être un des acteurs avec
une autre grande entreprise française de
la déconstruction que vous appelez
d'ailleurs vos voeux monsieur godefroy à
cherbourg et donc je crois que à travers
cette décision
ne faisons que continuer une évolution
nécessaire
et dieu sait qu'elle a été nécessaire on
a tellement tergiverser sur une autre
entreprise qui s'appelait giat que nous
avons été à deux doigts de ne plus avoir
dans l'industrie d'armement terrestre
cette industrie d'armement terrestre est
en train de renaître de ses cendres et
bien dcns a cette chance extraordinaire
c'est qu'alors qu'elle a à l'heure
actuelle quatre années de chiffre
d'affaires en commandes qu'il n'y a
aucune entreprise européenne qui peut
avoir une perspective à 10 ou 15 ans
compte tenu de nos programmes sur les
scènes et le sur les barracuda et bien
cet acteur industriel majeur doit être
le pivot
c'est marrant parce que moi je vous
interromps pas quand vous parlez ah bon
je m'écoutais je vais m'asseoir et puis
comme ça je vous laisserai parler et et
nous auront ainsi l'occasion de pouvoir
faire de dcns le pivot de reconstruction
de l'industrie européenne de défense est
pour moi je crois que c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour les salariés des sénès et
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour l'ensemble
des sites industriels de l'entreprise
alors je mets aux joies les trois
amendements 10 rectifié 90 des 123 qui
sont identiques ceux qui sont favorables
à leur adoption veut bien levé la main
habib contraire ils ne sont pas adoptées
et je met maintenant revoir l'article 10
je pense qu'il ya même vote pas
d'objection il est adopté à l'article 11
une demande de parole de monsieur pintât
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
l'article 11 prévoit la privatisation de
la société nationale des poudres et
explosifs snpe avec ses filiales renko
bnc ochem et s émeut dont les activités
le savoir faire sont éminemment
stratégique cette opération va nous
engager durablement aussi le transfert
de propriété de ce groupe doit
s'accompagner de garantie d'explication
pour réussir être compris et partagé par
ses salariés
c'était le sens est l'objet de
l'amendement que j'avais déposé en
commission et qui
reportée d'un an l'entrée en vigueur de
la privatisation j'ai accepté de le
retirer à la demande de notre président
pour répondre aux exigences nationales
d'une application rapide
oui rapide est attendue de la loi de
programmation militaire
néanmoins le contexte économique et
social est aussi une réalité avec
laquelle il faut compter
sachant que le bassin nautique aquitain
est fragile c'est pourquoi monsieur le
ministre je souhaiterais que vous
renault veut lier publiquement lors de
ce débat votre engagement de prendre en
compte des intérêts de ces sociétés et
de leurs personnels
car je reste convaincu que pour cette
réforme pour réussir doit être partagé
et recueillir l'adhésion la plus large
possible
il faut prendre le temps nécessaire pour
faire toute la clarté sur les chances et
les conditions de reprise des filiales
du groupe et s'assurer d'une solution
globale
je vous remercie vous souhaitez répondre
à ce monsieur le sénateur je sais que
vous suivez de près ce dossier et vous
savez j'ai l'occasion de vous répondre
lors de la réunion de commission ce qui
me permettra de répondre vous considérez
aussi que j'aurais répondu ainsi aux
amendements qui viendront de suppression
monsieur le président vous le savez une
évolution de snpe est nécessaire
j'allais dire que snpe c'est la même
problématique que nous avons connues sur
nexter ou sur giat à l'époque c'est une
entreprise dont qui connaît des pertes
chroniques je vous le rappelle 350
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
10% de son chiffre d'affaires en perte à
peu près chaque année les années où
l'entreprise a gagné de l'argent sont
nées entre eux deux années où
l'entreprise a cédé des actifs donc on
peut pas considérer que c'est un gain ou
un bénéfice lié à l'activité comme vous
le savez je le dis d'ailleurs au groupe
socialiste il s'agit de reprendre un
projet qui était aussi un projet d'alain
richard quesnel projet héraclès qui
consistait à faire en sorte que on
réorganise la snpe autour
de plusieurs entreprises safran pour la
propulsion solide
je vous transmettrai monsieur le
sénateur un document extrêmement
intéressant qui démontre aujourd'hui que
pour la propulsion du m51
alors vous ne voyez pas dû signer
l'organisation industrielle est
tellement complexe aujourd'hui c'est que
pour la seule propulsion du m51
nous avons neuf transfert de
responsabilités entre les sociétés
productive entre le début de la
construction de ce missile et
l'achèvement de ce missile je vous
transmettrai ce tableau ça c'est
intéressant et donc pardon oui parce que
ça ça n'a rien de fondamentalement
secret et monsieur pintât est un
parlementaire donc un homme responsable
et donc et donc nous allons mener cette
réorganisation avec le souci à la fois
de préserver les activités majeures
comme celle qui vous tient à coeur qui
est celle de saint médard en jalles de
faire en sorte que autour de safran nous
puissions préserver cette activité
majeure qui est notamment toute la
problématique de la propulsion solide
nous allons essayer de construire 1 1
un pôle munitionnaire qui nous manquent
soit avec nexter pour tout vous dire
j'ai rencontré les industriels ce matin
ce midi pour leur pour leur indiquer
quelles étaient les orientations de
l'état en la matière
donc soit avec nexter soit avec les
autres européens car vous le savez il y
à d'autres partenaires européens d'en
haut rhin co et sur un ca sur les partis
j'allais dire activités civiles nous
avons aussi les discussions qui sont
engagés avec cassandre de producteurs
j'ajoute par ailleurs que sur le sur le
site de sorgues 40 millions d'euros
d'investissements sont en cours preuve
s'il en est que l'entreprise est
considérée comme non pas une entreprise
qui donc il faut liquider mais au
contraire une entreprise qui consolider
et qui doit être consolidé par un
certain nombre d'investissements donc
soyez assurés que l'activité décide de
safran et snpe à saint médard en jalles
seront consolidés par les évolutions qui
sont encore merci maintenant alors
j'avais demandé à monsieur chevènement
nous présenté l'amendement 11 rectifier
oui messieurs président et demi c'est
une question de philosophie
personnellement je pense que l'industrie
de défense doit rester autant que
possible sous le contrôle de la
puissance publique par conséquent je
ressens tout à fait défavorablement la
privatisation de la snpe la snpe quatre
filiales l'une d'entre elles la fme
l'entreprise chimique que vous allez
fusionner avec un mécanicien privé
safran je ne vois pas quelles synergies
industrielles va dégager ce
rapprochement entre une entreprise
chimique est un fabricant de tuyères
attendait ses tableaux je veux bien le
regarder mais je suis pas sûr d'avoir
une compréhension immédiate instantané
oui donc si vous voulez un mécanicien
c'est un mécanicien un chimiste un
chimiste
moi je ne vois pas facilement dans ce
tableau complexe 1 ce qui conduit à
cette fusion est à cette privatisation
vous avez parlé de deux pôles
munitionnaire monsieur le ministre mais
savez-vous ce qu'étaient les
munitionnaire sous l'ancien régime et
ses rues ce qu'on leur reprochait un
c'était quand même de s'enrichir aux
dépens de la puissance publique itélé
puissance royale et ils ont fait fortune
et on ne sait pas ce qui se passera nous
ne sommes pas comme vous dites à l'abri
de surprises stratégique donc autres
pôles munitionnaire privée fera de très
bonnes affaires mais je dirais est ce
bien raisonnable bien écoutez je connais
pas exactement la composition du capital
enfin la privatisation 6 privatisation
ce n'est pas que l'état reste le
propriétaire vous nous engager dans un
processus où les différentes filiales de
la snpe isochem bergerac e jeu j'oublie
le nom bergerac nc 1 charest ya
suffisamment de chômeurs comme ça notre
industrie ne se porte pas si bien que
l'on puisse penser que vraiment ce soit
le moment de réaliser cette opération
mais c'est une question de philosophie
donc voila moi je ne suis pas d'accord
avec cette privatisation
vous venez de suivre la discussion de
l'article 5 sur la question du secret
défense je vous rappelle que la loi de
programmation militaire a été adopté
définitivement hier parler